bella tutti ragazzi e benvenuti a questo
video sono fa vj e dolcissimo sul grave
che un video giochi indie horror che c'è
scritto play oculus però non funziona
con l'occhio sinistro ragazzi perché c'è
la versione troppo vecchia per le
classifiche sono troppo aggiornato
quindi non funziona che cazzo sono già
partiti bello cioè non spiegheranno
spiega una sega come al solito ragazzi
c'è una casa già è bellissimo ci sono
ombre che si muovono di oggetti che non
ci sono perfetto è già bellissimo e sta
cosa
la più pallida idea di come ci sono
finito guarda da questo lo sappiamo
bello stop su mi piace
vabbè comunque c'è una casa quindi
l'unica cosa che vedo ci entrò perché
sennò è bello accogliente ragazzi di
provare un panino non lo so qualcosa
posso fare il caffè dato sembra
abbastanza pulito quindi va bene c'è un
copertone bellissimo ragazzi fantastici
frigo è la madonna abbiamo fatto la
spesa qui va beh io non ho paura che
vado al piano di sopra parliamo non sto
capendo che la nostra succedendo ma che
cazzo ragazze un c'è una scatola di
fiammiferi che si muove
vabbè po sopra grazie ho preso un
fiammifero farà normale fantastico c'è
la televisione ma prende sky e si
possono lanciare i fiammiferi basta la
mia vita e completano bisogno d'altro da
casa penso che prenderà fuoco in 4
secondi quindi meglio che mi lavo dai
[ __ ] perché sono visco male non ho
capito dove chi cazzo è quel tizio
ragazzi cè un amico mio avviene in
qualche show fiammiferi che ci
divertiamo a ragazzi se sarò bara c'era
sta cosa perché cazzo succede ragazze
ragazzi il personaggio sta andando sotto
effetto di droghe non fosse formale
credo
fantastico qualcuno mi spiega dove siamo
finiti di preciso e perfetto sembra
android ci avevo ragione io ho visto un
tizio che stava lì però adesso non c'è
più perché forse erano allucinazione
non lo so ma nel dubbio lancio
fiammifero poi sono comparsi degli
edifici ed è sparito a caso prova meglio
entrava dentro rado sono strutture
bellissimi complimenti dunque mi piace
la grazia con cui tiene il fiammifero
non è che lo tiene dritto lo tiene così
c'è la mano storta più storta del mondo
praticamente c'è un arc se sto coso
activate supplicano sono miniere
fantastico ragazzi sono finito nelle
miniere che è figo che sia anche
scontrati se sì ma vedevi star calmo
perché ti do fuoco
sì anche due vie fanta gonone bastava
una riga accaduto un po non sono io
lancio fiammiferi a non sono stato io
cazzola che ha fatto cadere sta roba
bene a sostare che non in pochissimo
sono divo le ombre che si muovono a caso
ragazzi non mi piace sta cosa
questa è arte moderna ragazzi vi insegno
io cioè si lanciano fiammiferi sull'arte
moderna quanto amo l'arte ragazzi però
non adesso non è la cosa che mi preme di
più cosa è stato perché trovo fattori
ovunque ho beccato una fattoria ho fatto
il caffè e poi io ho beccato delle
miniere poi un'altra fattoria per
bellissimo ragazzi cos'è ho preso una
batteria
la batteria rico dove sono spuntate stai
batteri era del fieno ma se diamo fuoco
alla roba chi se ne fotte
io non ho capito una torcia o mio dio
ragazzi tecnologia avanzata sta cosa ci
stiamo evolvendo
cos'è la tanica di benzina ma che cazzo
fai questo sì la forma gare si sta dando
fuoco a caso va beh io vado di sopra è
diventato questo è spuntato la gioia più
gioco sta roba è meno capito un cazzo è
stato frega un cazzo sei amiche one tu
sei figo
la ragazza è bellissimo c'è veramente
sexy però dopo konami ha steso ragazzi
questa specie sì ma stai calmo a sono
ripartito l'acqua dal check in check
point forza cioè io non so chi fosse
quel tizio però so che è un tipo sexy
questo l'ho capito però ha capito il
cazzo forse però ma stesso tipo wrestler
mezzo secondo prova bene la torcia auto
al perfetto questa mi serve a parte che
giorno la torcia di giorno non ci sono
videogiochi oro dove la torcia non la
trovi e non si vede un cazzo
il progetto invece si vede e trovi da
torcia fantastico activate perfetto
scusa attivato che qua tutto di legno
le luci quando diventa buio l'attivo
così diventa ci sono le luci e non mi
piglia non c'è una chiesa fantastica
cos'è ma x che sfrutta mi dovete
spiegare perché fluttuano gli oggetti
sto gioco
trovate un flare fantastico io continuo
a non capire la ecco che cosa sta
succedendo queste perché ci sono case
ovunque non è bello fanta no no
l'azzurro gara vediamo di capirci devo
tornare dopo attivare di nuovo il costo
della luce perché sono finisco malissimo
ok c'è una tanica intanto dove cazzo è
finito il comune la luce veloce veloce
la fiat può al giorno merda può [ __ ]
vabbè quanti siete però se sono uno che
ce n'è uno ogni 2 cm molto sei bello non
ancora non riesco a eccole qua e qua
devi morire una donna ma che cazzo
madonna si è bellissimo
[Musica]
basta è troppo troppo sex argini e poi
cazzo
c'è gente che cammina a caso si si
attiva dovete smetterla di fare sta
apparizioni tipo tipo hicks file vi
prego ragazzi non si è acceso un cazzo
non so perché prima ha funzionato le
sono processi point quello mi piace cioè
una bomba atomica sto coso non c'è poi
che non mi sei ma qui nessuno però mi fa
più paura sto coso e quelli di prima
sosta ho trovato un flash bang cioè una
granata accecante fare non capisco che
cosa devo farmi una grata cerca forse la
mancia quei tizi cioè se la lancia a sta
gente che mi compare davanti esco dovete
morire lo vedi questo dopo infilare nel
q ha funzionato cannes
non so che cosa ho fatto di preciso però
ha funzionato quindi va bene
credo che la luce e mandi via con gli
stronzi quindi se riesco ad attivare
questa merda non li transattiva cesto
skyphos attivati giorno ma di notte no
fantastico entità e non posso ormai ma
che lo faccia non funziona il fiammifero
fiammifero cioè seri che non sia micron
non prendono fuoco cose così il cazzo
andato eccolo fermi un attimo si tirò
fuoco tiro di morire ragazzi di sto
tirando i fiammiferi nel culo però non
si fa niente
e bellissima ragazza nuovo passatempo
basta ok esploso non ho capito che cosa
era arrivato giorno perfetto e se arriva
giorno esplodono fantastico pensavo di
averlo fatto esplodere fuori a di
fiammiferi nel culo ma non credo che sia
così siccome ragazzi il giorno e la
notte si alternano ogni 5 fottuti minuti
fatemi muovere il culo prima che succeda
qualcosa arto abbandonato non ho ancora
capito come ci sono arrivato qui sto
posto di me cos'è un'altra batteria che
fluttua fantasma posso dormire non posso
non posso dormire proprio centrare con
le gambe del letto che non ho fatto
no non dovete farvi cassino dovete farvi
cazzi vostri
i cazzi vostri merda esplosi da brava
prefetto e che a quello peso e chi cazzo
non sa son diversi questi
l'avanza c'hanno caso di madonna che
bello che sempre più test ok sono
esplosi tutti meno che quei due
devo forse lanciarli questo no no no si
mette male la faccenda non ci se ve ne
siete accorti però ragazzi sto mino
pieno di poor's continua a seguirmi
continua seguirli tra ok è esploso il
punto d'accordo ragazzi pronti a dare
indietro provvedesse succedere qualcosa
questo è successo di nuovo sotto effetto
di droghe ma basta è chiuso playing
crema nov a brno è finito così me lo
riassumo io perché non avete capito ma
io ho capito se era un drogato di caffè
che ha provato andare nel deserto per
trovare caffè pro non l'ha trovato mi
sono apparsi modelli di aver crombie in
giro che sarebbero questi tizi la morale
di tutto queste ragazze che non si beve
il caffè nel deserto sì più o meno
buongiorno ragazzi scelti due piaceva
scusatemi se durante così poco però non
pensavo che fosse così corto però i
modelli valevano tutto il gioco quindi
ragazze il video è piaciuto ma sui tassi
documento mi piace anche ai fagiani
facebook e come ogni video trovate nella
descrizione se attraversi iscrivetevi
non ci rivediamo il prossimo vinto
niente ragazzi
[Musica]